week end à rome donc pour les dirigeants
des grandes puissances mondiales c'est
aujourd'hui que s'ouvre le sommet du g20
pour la première fois depuis deux ans
les grands dirigeants se retrouveront en
personnes dans la capitale italienne
tout sauf de la dîmière poutine est dit
jean ping qui eux interviendront à par
visioconférence un sommet qui se déroule
dans un contexte particulier puisqu'il a
lieu à la veille de l'ouverture de la
com 26 le climat un des enjeux majeurs
de cette réunion ont fait le point avec
notre envoyé spécial à rome estelle
fâche
3p personnes planète prospérité
traduisez relance économique lutte
contre le coc vide 19 et climat ce sont
les trois gros dossiers au coeur de ce
g20 sous présidence italienne au coeur
des échanges tout de même le climat
mario draghi l'hôte de ce sommet avait
appelé dès début octobre pour un
engagement du g20 sur la nécessité de
limiter la hausse des températures à 1,5
degré un objectif ambitieux car si les
pays du g20 représentent la plus grosse
partie des émissions ils sont aussi est
très disparate sur leurs ambitions
certains visent par exemple la
neutralité carbone en 2050 quand
d'autres l'envisagent dix ans plus tard
il faut accélérer l'alluré sur le front
du climat de son côté alerté le
secrétaire général de l'onu antonio
guterres est ce qui tire la sonnette d
alarme sur le risque de catastrophes
climatiques malgré ces alertes la
capacité des états à s'entendre pendant
ce sommet sur des engagements forts sur
le climat n'est pas garanti et ce malgré
l ouverture de la coop 26 juste après
seule certitude d'avancées concrètes
pour ce sommet et c'est le dossier de la
fiscalité les chefs d'état devraient
ainsi entériner la taxation minimale
mondial de 15% sur les multinationales
un médecin il y a tout de même un défi
puisque chaque pays devra ensuite
traduire ce dispositif dans sa
législation
au menu aussi à de ce sommet des
rencontres bilatérales ou alors en petit
comité elle c'était le cas hier avec une
entrevue entre emmanuel macron et joe
biden deux chefs d'état qui se sont
employés à afficher leur réconciliation
après laffaire hocus emmanuel macron a
aussi a prévu de rencontrer dimanche
boris johnson le premier ministre
britannique dans le dossier de la pêche
poste breakes site source de tensions
entre les deux pays noter aussi que des
manifestations sont prévues dans la
capitale italienne elle 5000 policiers
et carabiniers sont ainsi mobilisés tout
le week end